أنت حذر للغاية ومتشكك إلى حد ما
بشأن العناوين الرئيسية
للأسبوع الماضي ، فهذه
بيانات أولية قفزة غير عادية ، لذا ما
ننتظره هو أننا ننتظر
التجربة الكبيرة والتي
تعني تجربة التحكم بالغفل المحتملة الكبيرة.
لديك 20000 شخص حصلوا على لقاح
10000 شخص حصلوا على دواء وهمي ،
وعندها فقط ستعرف ما إذا كان
اللقاح آمنًا وفعالًا
وسأفاجأ حقًا إذا
حدث كل هذا بحلول نهاية العام ، فعليك
أن تكون كذلك حقًا  محظوظ أيضًا تذكر
أنك تعلم أنك تريد الحصول على
عدد تمثيلي من حالات kovat
19 في مجموعة الدواء الوهمي ونحن
نتجه إلى الصيف حيث من المحتمل
أن يبدأ عدد الحالات
في الانخفاض بحيث يعمل هذا أيضًا ضد
هذه التجارب  لكن علينا انتظار
هذه التجارب الآن ، فهذه
بيانات مضيئة غير عادية ، لذلك دعونا
نتوخى الحذر حتى أعلم أنك تحترم د.
هل تعتقد فالتشي أنه ربما كان
ذلك بسبب تفاؤل الرئيس أم
أنه بعيد جدًا عن الوفرة غير المنطقية
أو هل تعتقد أنه بخير أم
لا ، فلا بأس أن تكون متفائلًا ، فلا بأس أن
تكون طموحًا على الرغم من أن هذه
العملية تعمل بطريقة معينة و  لقد
عملت بهذه الطريقة منذ
اختراع اللقاح الأول ، نحتاج إلى إجراء
أنواع التجارب التي تثبت لنا أن
شيئًا ما فعال وأثبت لنا
أنه آمن ، وهو ما يقلقني وهذا
هو أننا في أمس الحاجة إلى لقاح
لأننا  مرعوبون مجددًا بسبب
هذا الفيروس لأننا قد نكون مستعدين
لقبول شيء أقل وأعتقد أننا
مدينون للناس في هذا البلد
خاصة مع تذكر أن معظم الأشخاص
الذين يحصلون على هذا اللقاح سيكونون شبابًا يتمتعون بصحة جيدة
ومن غير المرجح أن
يموتوا بسبب هذا الفيروس  نحن مدينون لهم
بإجراء أنواع التجارب التي نقوم بها عادةً
للتأكد من أن هذا آمن
وفعال ويساعد في السياق الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين يعتقدون أنهم على ما يرام هناك مرة
واحدة  لقاح أذهب إلى طبيبي
أذهب إلى عيادة أحصل على حقنة. أنا بخير. أنا بخير
تمامًا. أخبار جيدة نشر
مقالًا مثيرًا للاهتمام هذا الأسبوع يقول
في الخيال العام
غالبًا ما يُنظر إلى اللقاحات على أنها علاج فعال - مثل
التطعيمات ضد الحصبة  بدلاً من
تلك اللقاحات ، فإن لقاحات Cova 19
قيد التطوير قد تكون أشبه
بتلك التي تحمي من الإنفلونزا
وتقلل من خطر الإصابة
بالمرض وتعاني من أعراض حادة في
حالة حدوث العدوى ، لذا فإن
شيئًا يساعدك لكنه لا
يعالجك يحميك تمامًا.  لذلك
قد تكون الحماية قصيرة الأجل وغير
مكتملة لفترة قصيرة ، أعني أنها قد
تستمر لمدة عام أو عامين فقط
، وما أعنيه غير مكتمل هو
أنها ستحميك من مرض معتدل إلى
شديد ولكن ليس مرضًا خفيفًا
مرتبطًا  مع الإصابة مرة أخرى ، وهي الحالة
التي ربما لا تزال تتخلص من الفيروس ، لذلك
أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى ذلك لأننا نعرف المزيد
عن هذه اللقاحات التي نحتاجها
لإدارة التوقعات حتى يتمكن الناس  يمكن أن تعرف
ما يمكن توقعه عندما تكون جميع هذه اللقاحات
خارج خط التجميع.
نشرت مجلة Proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences
أنه عندما يتعلق الأمر بـ Kovan 19 ، تُعتبر
قطرات الكلام الناتجة عن حاملين بدون أعراض
هي الطريقة المحتملة لانتقال المرض
، يبدو أن
العدوى بدون أعراض هي
محرك كبير للانتشار  من المرض وما
زلنا نتعلم أشياء عنه كل يوم ، وما زلنا نتعلم أشياء عنه
كل يوم ، وما ريماين هو صائد فيروسات
وعالم أوبئة مشهور في جامعة كاليفورنيا ، وقد
أمضى عقودًا في البحث في الكونغو في
محاولة لاستكشاف الفيروس التالي
وكيف ينتقل حتى الآن ، وهذا ما
يعرفه الخبراء أنه يساعد  وقف انتقال الفيروس التاجي
يجب على الجميع
البقاء بعيدين عن بعضهم البعض قدر
الإمكان وارتداء الأقنعة  التي ستقلل
من انتشار القطرات ولكن على بعد ستة أقدام من
المسافة الكافية ، يشير نموذج كمبيوتر جديد
إلى أنه قد لا يكون أستاذ الهندسة
دراسة لنموذج كمبيوتر
نُشر في مجلة فيزياء
السوائل تظهر أن النسيم الخفيف يمكن أن يحمل
بعض القطرات على مسافة 18 قدمًا  أي
بيانات مهمة لتكون قادرًا على التفكير في
أننا نجمع البيانات حرفيًا في
الوقت الفعلي لفهم ما نقوم به
اليوم وغدًا لا يزال من غير المعروف
كيف يمكن أن تكون هذه القطيرات معدية
إذا كان الفيروس يمثل خطرًا مطلقًا
للإصابة  عندما يكون هناك مثل الفوز
ويكون مكانك في الهواء الطلق في
الواقع صغيرًا جدًا
، لم يتم اختبار نموذج الكمبيوتر علميًا في
سيناريوهات الحياة الواقعية ، ما الذي تم اختباره في المختبر إلى أي
مدى يمكن للقطرات أن تتفرق في
الداخل ، فكر في مراكز التسوق والمطاعم في العطلات الصيفية.
هي تجربة المعاهد الوطنية
للصحة التنفس الطبيعي
بدون قناع تحت
ضوء ليزر شديد الحساسية يظهر عدم وجود قطرات تضيء
ولكن عندما y  أنت تتحدث عن قطرات تضيء
مثل شجرة عيد الميلاد ، ومن المفارقات أن
إحدى العبارات التي تنتج عددًا كبيرًا
من القطرات هي
وأبواب التابوت التي أظهرها علماء في
جامعة فلوريدا أتلانتيك ، بدون
قناع ، يمكن أن تنتشر قطرات القطرات 12 قدمًا
بقناع بسيط لا تزال القطرات تنتشر
ولكن بعيدًا  أقل لسوء الحظ بالنسبة
لعشاق الرياضة الصيفية ، يمكن للهتاف المتحمسين
أيضًا أن ينثر قطرات أخرى قد
ينتقل الفيروس من مشجع إلى آخر ، فهو يحب
الأنف والفم ، إنه مثل
فندق من فئة الخمس نجوم بالنسبة للفيروس ، قد يؤدي الهتاف
والأطفال الصغار إلى هزيمة جهود
السيطرة  الفيروس الذي يفسر
فكرة اللعب في الملاعب الفارغة في
الملعب يشبه حضانة الكبار ، ولكن
لا يتم فقدان كل شيء وهو ما يزال باردًا
وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض ، ولا يوجد
دليل على أن الفيروس يمكن أن ينتشر عبر
مياه البركة ولكن لا يزال الإبعاد الذاتي
مفتاح أننا سنتعايش مع
هذا الفيروس لفترة طويلة ربما إلى الأبد
يبدو وكأنه عطلة مدرسية عادية
في المدرسة في كوبنهاغن باستثناء
f  أو شريط الشرطة الذي يقسم
فناء المدرسة ، فقط أحد الإجراءات العديدة التي
تهدف إلى منع الأطفال من التكدس
ومنع انتشار الفيروس
التاجي ، يقول رئيس التعليم الثانوي
إذا اتبعت الإرشادات المعطاة إذا
حافظت على مسافة إذا تأكدت من غسل
يديك  استمر في تعقيم السعال
في جعبتك وليس في يدك وما إلى
ذلك وما إلى ذلك
، أعتقد أننا سنكون بأمان بدأت الدنمارك في
إعادة فتح المدارس منذ أكثر من
شهر وحتى الآن لم تتسبب حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا الجديد في
البلاد في ارتفاع الحكومة
تقول ما هو  من المفاجئ أنه
لا يرتدي الطلاب ولا المعلمون الأقنعة
بدلاً من ذلك ، فهم يبقون على مسافة ويغسلون
الأيدي ويعقمون في كثير من الأحيان ، فهذا يمثل تحديًا بعض الشيء
ولكنك تعتاد على ذلك
بعد مرور الوقت ، إنها صورة مختلفة في
كوريا الجنوبية ، حيث لا
يرتدي الأطفال الأقنعة فقط ، وبعضهم يجلس خلف
زجاجي  الفواصل لمنع العدوى
لا تزال البلاد تغلق عشرات
المدارس بعد أن أثبتت إصابة طفلين
بالفيروس حتى أول بؤرة رئيسية لفيروس كورونا في
ووهان  أعادت الصين الأطفال إلى الوراء
قبل أسبوعين قبل عام ، هناك قناعان
إلزاميان ويقول رئيس المدرسة
إنه تم اتخاذ تدابير صارمة أخرى
للشيعة وأعاد الشاب الهاواي
ترتيب المرافق في الحرم الجامعي لضمان أن يكون
لكل فصل مرحاض خاص به يقول
إنه يمتلك غرفة مياه مغلية و
أعادت فرنسا فتح الفصول الدراسية البديلة الخاصة بها
الأسبوع الماضي ، لكنها اضطرت بالفعل إلى
إغلاق بعضها مرة أخرى بعد تسجيل
عشرات حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا الذي لا يزال
وزير التعليم في فرانسيس يقول إنه
يعتقد أن الأطفال يقومون
بدورهم ، ويتفهم التلاميذ
قواعد التباعد الاجتماعي التي يقول ارتداء
الأقنعة  وفي بعض الحالات ، يوضحون
الطريق بما في ذلك للبالغين لأنهم
يفهمون ما هو على المحك
تقول الدنمارك إنها تأمل في إعادة جميع
الطلاب إلى المدرسة الأسبوع المقبل ، لكن
قواعد الإبعاد الجسدي تعني أنه
ليس لديهم مساحة لهم جميعًا ،
لذا فهم يتحركون بشكل إبداعي  بعض
الفصول في الكنائس المحلية وحتى
مقابر الكنيسة كلها لمحاولة ضمان حصول
الأطفال على هذه الدروس  دروسهم حتى في
أوقات الوباء فريد بليتجن سي إن إن
برلين